um it's on succession where uh Brian
Cox's character says everything I do I
do for my kids Mark Wahlberg on his
terrible reality show I say terrible
because it's just reality yeah uh he
also goes everything I do I do for my
kids right yeah and my my father three
Impressions my father also goes
everything I do I do for my kids that's
my father and uh I always get really lit
up when when men especially successful
men all three of those examples are
successful men that are doing well
um say that what they do is for their
kids and there's a lot of reasons sure
but talk about identity one dad or or
Brian or Mark if you stopped working
you'd vanish that's point one you'd go
like it's death yeah yeah to lose your
your place your purpose or your power is
actually a better a better way to put it
yeah you lose your power and part of
that is this is how I don't know how to
make this funny being a person who
provides for his kids is one of the
cornerstones of your identity so that's
about you too right do you see what I'm
saying yeah it's like your job is part
of your identity and and I provide for
my kids is also part of my identity I'm
not saying that's not a good thing to do
I'm saying at a certain point of success
can you please stop saying it's for your
kids and just go this is for me this is
also a good lesson to teach your kids
like I want you to do things that make
you happy yeah and I'm going to model
that for you absolutely have to do a
private show I mean I certain I
certainly do I build and all that sort
of stuff but like at a certain point
yeah why can't you just be like it's for
me and you happen to be here
it's for me and you happen to be here
all right when you give money to someone
on the street
yeah I want him to be but it's for you
but I feel I bet you I feel better than
he does
I'm gonna guarantee that
as much as I walk away thinking what a
great how great am I yeah I mean come on
you get the hit I am pretty great and
it's not just yeah it's it's the thought
I'm the kind of guy who helps people in
need which is okay it's okay because now
you're helping people in need and we'll
take kindness however we can get it and
whatever your motivation is right and
you know what my father and Mark
Wahlberg and the fictional character of
Logan Royce did feed and and shelter
their families that's right but at a
certain point uh let's just stop nobody
likes us need to say out loud that I
love money and accolades
so but I'm gonna say it's for the kids
that's exactly maybe it's a he goes I
love
when people give me action I'm great
I love when people think I'm better than
them I love it I mean what's what's
better than being on a movies can you
imagine being on a movie set and you're
Mark Wahlberg and you're the star of the
movie Mr Wahlberg here's your herbal tea
get this out of here
I'm doing squats like it's the best is
this for my kids yeah and this these
spots are for my kids they moved my gym
on a truck here it's for my kids right
it's for you to feel like a special baby
boy yeah just be more honest you love
you made it funny it's for me and you
happen to be here it's for me and you
happen to be here and I love money right
and uh I just love money the rush of it
if my father was just like Peter I just
love the ups and the Downs of it way
more than anything you've ever done I
mean like I don't know that's true yeah
uh but I worry that I've Had My Moments
with you yeah but when a big contract
comes in oh you pay off me but when
you're on the line for 50 large or
whatever it is
[Music]